hey what's up BuzzFeed it's amber Liu
here and I am here to do a was a three
billion question what it what's up you
guys my name is amber Lou I'm here at
BuzzFeed to do 30 questions in three
minutes
[Music]
stitch oh that's not fair other people
my son Jack Jack this guy this guy this
guy from my sister she says the the rope
no my sister said something um
you can't control what the world does to
you but you can control how you react to
it video with babish okay it is a honey
lemon black tea half sugar no ice double
boba grass jelly these are really hard
questions wait hold on hold on you can
go edit this down hold on how far I'll
go from Moana the Jackie Chan I don't
know does this get all the curves or the
curves I've been trying to make being
alone
Oh
[Music]
that's unfair Tori Kelly but not like
clap with her music I just want to like
sit in the studio Interscope yeah and
then hopefully that makes it in in the
song as a soundbite I would scream and
probably shave because Eric has really
big facial hair
Hawaii um probably the worst my chest
video because I just gave no that's that
day the Purple Heart for my fans
cucumber a hot mess oh oh
Megan dia yours it's it's a heartwarming
moment when fans are crying and they're
like I'm sorry I'm crying I'm like no
you don't have to cry and then they
proceeded to cry and we hug and I'm like
letting them cry cuz it's okay to cry
and it's Katie feel things and I
appreciate that Engrish over who doesn't
understand fair you need to calm the F
down and trust that people around you
love you and appreciate you and you do
it okay and don't worry so much okay so
worry too much
yeah I got through it yeah I can't come
down hard that's really unfair may be
true but see my kids
how dare thank you guys for watching
this video um I'm on tour X right now um
come see if you want and check out my
new EP X it has songs in it and it's a
hot mess
love you guys hi watch other BuzzFeed
with yes and break a lot of Bobo
Ilan cucumbers post their hydrating get
sleep
[Music]